what is going on everybody welcome to
part three of our Python with PI QT for
creating gooeys tutorial video series in
this video what we're going to be doing
is adding a button to our windows the
first thing I always think of when I'm
creating windows is okay how do I add a
button so that's what we're going to
talk about next so to add a button the
first thing that we're going to have to
also import is going to be QT core now
in theory we could actually add a button
without QT core we just need the Qt GUI
to create a button and make it do like
button presses and stuff but to make it
actually do anything like you know have
any event handling we use QT core so
once we have that we're ready to move on
now just a quick note about our
structure here so the init method what
it does is it runs every time it's the
initial thing that runs every time we
make it a window object this init is
going to run so that means every time we
make a window object like we have down
here this in it runs and it runs all of
this code so it's supers window it does
geometry 50 50 500 300 does the window
title window icon and it shows now what
we want it to do instead is instead of
self dot show we wanted to run self dot
home now home is in reference to a
method which does not exist does it have
a queue in front of it no so home
doesn't exist yet so let's go ahead and
make our own and so we're going to say
define home and pass the obligatory self
and now we're going to add some stuff
here so my theory here is the init is
any kind of like core application stuff
is going to be here so if you have a
main menu you're going to put that in
the init okay is that because that makes
sense it's going to be there no matter
what so it's almost like a template
right for the rest of your your GUI but
the home is going to be stuff that's
like specific to that certain space that
you're on so we're going to have define
home self and then what we're going to
do is we're going to have some a button
so buttons are generally short-handed as
etn so we're going to follow that sort
of principle QT GUI q push button and
then this button has just basically one
parameter that you have to put in and
that's going to be what do you want that
button to say we want the button to say
quit so then quit and then pass self
next BTN clicked dot connect now
generally let me make some space so we
can come down generally whenever you
have an event you're going to have this
dot connect and then you pass through a
method function whatever so we're going
to pass through something that's already
built into QT but I'll show you in the
next video how you can make your own but
we'll just use theirs for now
QT core Q core application so QT core q
core application dot instance parms
quit so what this basically does is
exits the current instance of your Q
core application okay that's all so it
runs that and it'll go away now what
we're going to do that basically defines
or excels what tells this connect method
basically what are we going to do when
the button is clicked and then what
we're going to do is we're going to say
BTN and we'll do actually it will just
show this for now so now let's just do
self dot show empty parameters finally
generally you're going to have a some
sort of main loop here so you'll see
people to maybe do define main and they
run main so or that you might have like
run here we'll just use run for now it
doesn't really matter but you should
have some sort of main kind of running
applicator function so we'll tab
everything over put this up here and
then we'll call run to run and that
should be it so let's make sure
everything worked up to this point so
here we have our button we've got quit
pie cutie Tut's we hit quit
sure enough the application closes when
we hit quit awesome so now the only
other thing I want to show you guys with
buttons is resizing so just like the
window you can resize
choose a specific size otherwise you can
use the default of course but let's say
we want to make it 100 by 100 so we'll
do 100 by 100 button and then what if we
don't want it right in that corner what
if we want to button dot move and we'll
move that button also to 100 100 so we
can save and run that and there's our
button in the middle it's a nice perfect
square and it's a hundred by a hundred
and again that's from here not from like
here okay and then we can still quit and
all of that okay so that's a real simple
example of implementing buttons and of
course there's a lot more to go
as far as creating your own methods here
so that's probably we're going to do in
the next video and there's a couple
other things with resizing and moving
which we'll also cover in the next video
so if you have any questions or comments
up to this point please feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions and until next
time